[Music]
today's question comes from lexi in
texas and i finished it out is on the
script uh last year i started a real
estate career and very quickly became
successful so far i've closed 22
transactions and have four more to close
this month way to go lexi made more
money than i have earned in my past jobs
i have eighteen thousand dollars in
savings personal loans of ten thousand a
forty four thousand dollar car loan and
my mortgage is nine is a hundred and
ninety thousand i am deathly afraid to
give up my savings and i am even more
scared about doing things wrong i want
my kids to have the best and i do not
want to struggle doing it how do i get
started
it's a lot like see but yeah congrats
amazing what a great job to be in right
now it's real estate especially when you
are the agent it's awesome
uh so yeah you're 18 000 in savings i
mean i would today depending and you
didn't say how much you made in a year
even though you said you've made uh more
than you have in your past jobs which is
awesome
i mean i would consider selling the car
44 000 car loan that's a lot so consider
selling that uh but depending on what
you can get the car market's insane
right now so you'd have to run the
numbers on that but i would definitely
take money out of my savings you have 18
000 in savings go ahead and pay off your
personal loans and then you can just
start checking away at that car loan uh
as well if you choose not to sell
you know even if you do choose to sell
and you move in half
because lexi here's the thing
you're in the real estate business 22
transactions you're doing a lot of
volume you're doing a lot of driving and
it's bad driving it's hard on a car and
so you are destroying whatever you drive
and to destroy a 55 000 or 50 000 car in
the real estate business is silly
when a
really really nice uh
7 series beamer
or uh
mercedes or cadillac will do just fine
and you can get a really nice one for 20
grand
and it and 99 of people walking around
can't tell the difference in a
four-year-old beamer 7
series or a brand new one i mean they
really don't know
and and so we're not trying to impress
anybody nobody buys a house from you
because of the car you drive you just
need something that looks reasonably
prosperous and that is reasonably
reliable um and that's what you need uh
or if you're driving suv that's fine too
but move down girl you're spending
you're destroying an expensive car even
if it was paid for i would tell you to
do this i wouldn't tell you to drive a
50 000 or 60 000 car in the real estate
business i wouldn't do it it's a bad use
of money if you want a car like that you
got extra money laying around you want
to leave in the driveway fine but i
wouldn't use it in the real estate
business
you're making enough money to not be
scared 22 transactions you're doing fine
you are the secret sauce to this
equation and you are very good you're
doing a great job